PROFESSOR: So again,
much of the difficulty
here is just making sure you're
doing the perturbation theory
right and working with
the two basis correctly.
But now we're in
the good position.
We can combine our results.
So here is what I
want to combine.
I want, in principle, to combine
all the things, all the terms.
And we've calculated all
the terms to some degree.
So we saw the Darwin term
only affects l equals 0.
On the other hand, spin orbit
really requires s dot l.
And the state should be
acted nontrivially by l.
If all your states are
singlets, l gives 0 on them.
So actually, you
have a little bit
of an uncomfortable situation
because l acting on l
equals 0 states will give you 0.
But you still have
the 1 over r cubed.
And the 1 over r cubed
has l dependencies here.
So it's 0 in the denominator,
0 in the numerator.
The whole spin orbit
coupling doesn't seem
to make sense for l equals 0.
So most people say, physically,
the spin orbit coupling
vanishes for l equals 0.
It should not be there.
But then something
very funny happens.
If you take a proper limit
of this as l goes to 0,
it gives you, for the spin
orbit result, the same thing
as the Darwin result.
So for l equals 0,
the spin orbit limit is
actually the same as the Darwin.
It's almost as if
you say, oh, the spin
orbit has everything in it.
But it's not legal
for l equals 0.
But the Darwin does it.
So if I put together the
spin orbit and relativistics
for l different
from 0, I'm legal.
For l equals 0, I should really
sum relativistic and Darwin.
But actually, it
turns out that it's
the same as summing
relativistic plus spin orbit.
Because the limit of
spin orbit for l equals 0
is equal to the Darwin.
So we will just sum
relativistic plus spin orbit.
And that gives the result
for everything, including
Darwin for l equals 0.
So this is minor subtlety.
But the end result is
that we can combine it.
So the happy thing, as well,
is that we now can do this.
mj delta H relativistic plus
delta H spin orbit nljmj.
Because whatever
we calculated here
was actually the same
that H relativistic
in the coupled basis.
And anyway, the spin orbit,
we use the coupled basis
to get this number.
So this thing, you can
add the two results,
and you get En0 squared
over 2mc squared 3 plus n
J j plus 1 minus 3l l
plus 1 minus 3/4 over l l
plus 1/2 l plus 1--
a little messy.
OK.
Something very
unexpected happens now.
It's something that when you do
the algebra yourself, you say,
wow.
How did that happen?
Here is the issue.
We are trying to compute the
splittings of the hydrogen
atom.
And for this, as we said
in the coupled basis,
the degeneracies happen
for a given value of n.
I'm getting good at
doing this diagram now.
So we're looking at the fixed n.
And then, you have all kind of
degenerate states for various
l's and j's.
So is there a better way
to rewrite this formula?
And you say the following--
suppose you think of
some states of fixed j--
fixed j states-- j.
For example, this state-- we'll
use our l equals 1 over here--
I have 1, 2, 3--
3P 3/2 and 3P 1/2.
Here, I have 3D 5/2
because this is l equals 2.
So 2 plus 1/2 and 2 minus 1/2.
So I have here
states of fixed j--
two states with the same j.
But they come from
different l's.
Because when you get a
total j of some value,
it can come from a lower l--
l plus 1/2 gives you that j--
or it can come from a top l with
l minus 1/2 giving you that j.
So a given j value can arise
from an l that is 1/2 higher
or an l that is 1/2 lower.
So for a fixed j, it may be
that l is equal to j minus 1/2,
or l is equal to j plus 1/2.
Now, look at this quantity.
We'll call this whole
quantity f of jl.
Very astonishingly, f of jl when
l is j minus 1/2, or f of jl
where l is j plus 1/2,
you can calculate it.
Put l equals j minus
1/2 on that formula.
And then put l equals j
plus 1/2 in that formula.
You would say, it's
going to be a mess.
In fact, both
cases are the same.
And it give you minus
2 over a j plus 1/2.
So the whole l dependence
here, amazingly, is fake.
There's no l dependence
in this factor.
It is a little strange.
There's no l dependence because,
given j, l can be two values.
And for those two values, that
function gives you the same.
It's one of those, like x
squared gives the same for 1
and minus 1.
This function, once you
fix j, l can be two values.
And it so happens that these
two values give the same.
So at the end of the day,
this just depends on j.
That's the most important
result of this lecture.
The whole structure,
once you put relativity,
Darwin, and spin orbit,
just depends on j.
And what is the result
when you simplify this?
Our result is that the
fine structure Enljmj--
fine structure 1-- is equal to
minus alpha to the fourth mc
squared 1 over 2n to the fourth
n over j plus 1/2 minus 3/4.
Whole answer, all together--
Darwin fine spin orbit
and relativistic.
So a few comments about this.
People that look at
the Dirac equation
more seriously would have
expected this result.
It turns out that in the
Dirac equation, the symmetry
and the rotations--
the generator of rotations--
is exactly j, which is l plus s.
That generates rotation.
That commutes with
the Hamiltonian.
So you should expect that
the energy eigenstates
are j eigenstates.
So here, we're seeing
that, yes, they can
be simultaneously diagonalized.
The eigenstates can also
be labeled by the j value.
So the exact eigenstates
in the Dirac equation
can be labeled by the
j value, and we're
seeing a reflection of this.
This means that the j multiplets
are not going to be split,
and there's going to be,
moreover, some degeneracy.
They're not split because
there's no mj dependence.
And they are all
going to be the same.
So let me finish by drawing
how the spectrum looks.
It's pretty important
to see that.
This quantity over here,
this numerical quantity,
is always positive--
positive-- for any state
in the hydrogen atom.
You can see that because j max--
the maximum value--
so this is negative.
So you need to know what is the
minimum value of this quantity
to see if it goes negative.
The minimum value of this
ratio is when j is maximum.
The maximum j is when j is l
plus 1/2 with the maximum l.
So this is l plus 1 maximum.
But l plus 1 maximum
is, in fact, n.
So the minimum
value of this is 1.
So this is always positive.
As n increases, the
corrections become smaller.
So what happens?
All the corrections
are negative.
So if you had the original
states, they all go down a bit.
Even the ground state
goes down a bit.
1S 1/2 is down.
Because for n equal
1, you do get a state.
Then what do you get?
2S 1/2 is here.
It's also down a bit.
3S 1/2-- so this is l equals 0.
Then you have l equals 1.
Remember, what did we have here?
We have 2P 1/2 and 2P 3/2.
Because l equal 1 gives
you j equals 3/2 and 1/2.
Look, these two remain
degenerate because they
have the same n and the same j.
And that's all that matters.
So 1/2 and 1/2 have the same
j, so they remain degenerate.
2P 3/2 has a higher
j, therefore,
has a smaller number.
So it's lowered less, and
it appears a little higher.
So here, you would have
3P 1/2 and here, 3P 3/2.
And the next state here is 3D.
Now you're combining l equal 2.
So you get 5/2 and 3/2.
The 3/2 is degenerate with this
3/2 because it has the same j.
And the 5/2 is a little higher--
3D 5/2.
So this is our final picture.
The hydrogen atom, all the
states get pushed down.
The various multiplets with
different l but the same j
are still degenerate.
This formula has
no l dependence.
So these two are the same.
These two are the same.
Moreover, the j
multiplets are not split.
Every j multiplet differs
[? because of ?] a collection
of states with different mj.
But mj doesn't appear.
So this is your fine
structure of hydrogen atom.
And this is where you study
in detail the Zeeman splitting
and the Stark splitting.
And we'll talk a
little bit about them
next time, as we
will begin, also,
our study of the
semiclassical approximation.
See you then.